salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
lorsqu'on surf sur internet avec un
ordinateur ou un smartphone on laisse
inévitablement des traces de notre
passage notre adresse numérique notre
adresse
IP ou encore ces fameux cookies qu'on
nous demande d'accepter ou de refuser
quand on consulte ainsi toutes ces
informations permettent de nous pister
la plupart du temps pour nous proposer
de la publicité pour des produits qui
sont censés nous intéresser pour éviter
ce désagrément certains ont trouvé la
parade ils utilisent la navigation
privée mais est-ce vraiment efficace
peut-on naviguer sur Internet sans être
tracée en mode incognito
bonjour Jamy
pour le savoir je vais d'abord vous
expliquer quelles sont les réelles
différences entre le mode classique et
la navigation privée aussi appelé mode
incognito il y a quatre différences la
navigation privée ne conserve pas votre
historique de navigation si vous
cherchez à faire un cadeau à une
personne qui partage votre ordinateur
c'est pour le coup très utile les
données saisies dans les formulaires que
ce soit votre numéro client votre
adresse mail de connexion à Facebook ne
seront pas retenues par votre navigateur
c'est pratique si vous surfez sur un
ordinateur qui ne vous appartient pas
troisièmement les extensions que vous
utilisez sont désactivées par défaut et
enfin les fameux cookies ne sont pas non
plus stockés par votre navigateur voilà
c'est tout comment je le sais c'est
écrit noir sur blanc à l'ouverture de la
fenêtre ou plutôt blanc sur noir si j'ai
bien compris si les cookies sont bloqués
vous êtes tranquille vous pouvez surfer
un Cognito non pas vraiment j'habite
déjà les cookies ne sont pas les plus
méchants de l'histoire un cookie c'est
un fichier texte plus exactement une
variable avec un nom et une valeur
associée et il existe c'est pour une
bonne raison il permet de stocker des
petites informations utilisées par
quasiment tous les sites web la langue
que nous utilisons ce que nous avons mis
dans notre panier de tel ou tel site
d'e-commerce ou encore nos identifiants
pour nos connecter à notre boîte mail ou
n'importe quel autre service en ligne la
fameuse case se souvenir de moi et
croyez moi au bout de la troisième
connexion à vos mails en une journée de
navigation privée vous en aurez déjà
marre de devoir saisir vos identifiants
à chaque fois bref vous l'aurez compris
un cookie c'est utile jusqu'au jour où
les publicités y ont vu une opportunité
en or de mieux nous connaître les fameux
cookies tiers ce sont les fameuses
bannières acceptées tous les cookies ça
je connais à l'origine les cookies sont
déposés par le site web que nous sommes
en train de consulter ça paraît plutôt
logique mais les cookies sont comme leur
nom l'indique déposés par des tiers il
s'agit par exemple de régies
publicitaires très puissante comme
Google ou Facebook c'est cookies leur
permettent de connaître quelle page nous
avons visité de déterminer nos habitudes
sur Internet et de constituer un profil
complexe de notre personnalité afin de
nous afficher de la publicité très
ciblée en développant des outils très
pratiques et gratuits pour les
développeurs de sites web ces régies
font en sorte d'être présentes partout
sur le web ainsi grâce au cookies à
l'aide de ces outils ils sont en
capacité de nous suivre quasiment à la
trace sur Internet et de toujours mieux
connaître nos habitudes tenez par
exemple si je fais une recherche pour
m'acheter une nouvelle machine à café
sur un site spécialisé et bien je serai
automatiquement ciblé sur tous les sites
que je consulterai les jours suivants
par des publicités de machines à café ça
m'arrive tout le temps j'en ai marre si
j'ose dire oui Jamy c'est un peu pénible
et ça porte un nom le retard getting on
s'est amusé à faire le test avec le
profil d'un membre de l'équipe sur
Facebook c'est impressionnant tout ce
que ce réseau social a collecté
d'informations sur ces centres
d'intérêts et c'est exactement la même
chose
[Musique]
jusqu'à nous lors d'un téléchargement
illégal enfin une dernière méthode
existe pour nous pister sans l'aide des
cookies tir ni de notre adresse IP le
finger printing nos empreintes digitales
et c'est absolument redoutable
mes empreintes digitales comment font
les sites pour mettre la main sur mes
empreintes digitales
mais de celle de ton navigateur je vous
explique pour qu'un site Web s'affiche
correctement il a besoin de connaître
tout un tas de détails techniques à
propos de votre navigateur sa largeur la
langue utilisée la résolution de notre
écran la présence d'extension la liste
des polices installées j'en passe mais
mise bout à bout toutes ces spécificités
anodines au premier abord constitue
l'empreinte quasiment unique de mon
navigateur ou du tien j'ai mis doux le
parallèle avec les empreintes digitales
une enquête de l'EFF l'électronique
frontière Foundation une ONG respectée
dans le milieu du numérique a montré que
83,6% de nos navigateurs utilisent une
empreinte unique votre navigateur ou
plutôt son empreinte a de très grandes
chances d'être uniques cette empreinte
existe également sur nos téléphones et
les développeurs d'applications vont
d'ailleurs très bien compris en 2021
quand Apple a imposé son App tra
vous savez cette petite pop up qui
demande aux utilisateurs d'iPhone à
l'ouverture d'une application s'il
souhaite être suivi et bien les
applications basées sur la pub ont vu le
revenu s'effondrer pour y faire face et
contourner cette mesure certains
développeurs ont donc pris le parti
d'utiliser le finger printing de votre
téléphone afin de vous identifier malgré
tout du coup Michael la navigation
privée ça ne sert pas à grand chose mais
si jamais elle est toujours utile mais
uniquement dans un cas bien précis si
vous utilisez une machine partagée un
ordinateur familial ou un ordinateur
public dans ce cas la navigation privée
vous garantit de ne pas rester connecté
à votre boîte mail par mégarde ou de
dévoiler toutes vos recherches dans
l'historique du navigateur en résumé ce
que fait la navigation privée nous
pouvons le reproduire à l'identique en
navigation classique simplement en
effaçant l'historique les cookies et les
données de formulaire enregistrés en
revanche si vous cherchez à vous cacher
de votre fournisseur accès à Internet du
Réseau de votre employeur des grandes
entreprises du numérique et de la
publicité ciblée ou même des espions et
services de renseignements la navigation
privée n'offre absolument aucune
protection supplémentaire par rapport à
la navigation classique vos données de
navigation sont toujours accessibles par
des tirs c'est d'ailleurs très utile
pour la police qui peut saisir votre
ordinateur dans le cadre d'une enquête
vous pensez avoir effacé votre
historique mais en réalité il ne l'est
pas de façon sécurisée en utilisant des
techniques particulières les enquêteurs
sont capables de remonter jusqu'à vos
données effacées on appelle ça l'analyse
for ensick vous l'avez compris la
navigation privée est à dissocier de la
navigation anonyme seulement avec la
petite image d'espion à lunettes et leur
terminologie de navigation incognito les
navigateurs Web sont les premiers à
entretenir ce flou Google avec son
navigateur Chrome et d'ailleurs en
procès pour tromperie à ce sujet il y a
quand même une chose qui me turlupine
existe-t-il vraiment un moyen de rester
anonyme sur Internet oui l'idée serait
d'utiliser un intermédiaire un tiers de
confiance au lieu de se connecter à un
site Web en notre nom avec notre adresse
IP on le ferait via un ou plusieurs
ordinateurs intermédiaires pour
brouiller les pistes cette intermédiaire
on appelle ça un proxy pour mettre en
place cette technique beaucoup vont
recommander un VPN un réseau privé
virtuel qui pour simplifier consiste à
rebooter l'ensemble de votre trafic via
un ordinateur intermédiaire
potentiellement à l'autre bout de la
planète ça fonctionne mais ça revient à
déplacer le problème de notre opérateur
internet à notre VPN et je suis pas bien
sûr d'avoir envie de faire confiance à
une société au Panama en revanche il
existe un réseau un peu particulier le
réseau tort pour des onlyons routeurs
c'est un réseau mondial et décentralisé
superposé au réseau classique qu'on
connaît tous associés à son navigateur
il transmet chaque requête à au moins
trois serveurs 3 proxy choisis au hasard
à l'image des couches d'un oignon et
c'est pour le coup plutôt efficace et
sécuriser enfin la façon la plus
efficace de ne pas laisser de trace
c'est d'en laisser le moins possible
initialement et de tout détruire en
partant pour ça il existe des systèmes à
installer directement sur une clé USB on
peut alors être protégé quelle que soit
l'ordinateur qu'on utilise et doit
Snowden lui-même le lanceur d'alerte de
la NSA recommande ce système vous
connectez la clé USB à un ordinateur que
ce soit le vôtre ou celui de quelqu'un
d'autre et dès lors toutes les
connexions transites par le réseau Thor
rien n'est stocké sur le disque dur de
l'ordinateur tout est indépendant quand
vous débranchez la clé USB tout est
effacé c'est comme si vous n'étiez
jamais passé par là c'est bien beau
Michael mais tout le monde n'est pas
Edward Snowden ni journaliste
d'investigation le mieux c'est donc de
commencer par refuser les cookistiaires
et les traqueurs ce sera déjà un très
bon début et comme la tâche et pour le
monde ardu et bien des extensions pour
votre navigateur permettent de faire ce
travail à votre place refusez
automatiquement les cookies et empêcher
les traqueurs d'agir certes vous ne
serez pas anonyme mais vous serez moins
suivi allez merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout c'est le meilleur
soutien que vous pouvez nous apporter et
si ce type de sujet vous plaît n'hésitez
pas à nous en proposer d'autres on
regardera ça de très près avec Michael
allez à très bientôt les chers
épicurieuses et épicurieux
[Applaudissements]